[Música]
finlandia y suecia están cada vez más
cerca de su adhesión a la otan durante
décadas estos dos países escandinavos se
mantuvieron neutrales en medio de las
latente rivalidades entre occidente y
moscú de concretarse esta ampliación de
la otan supondría un cambio destacable
en el tablero geopolítico internacional
con implicaciones futuras el secretario
general de la otan james tot el ver que
se ha referido a ambos países como los
socios más cercanos a la alianza militar
y por su parte el presidente ruso
vladimir putin ha dicho no tener
problemas con finlandia y suecia pero
que la expansión de la infraestructura
militar de su territorio demandaría una
reacción desde moscú para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestro primer invitado
del día y es la doctora maribel
contreras suárez analista de asuntos
globales y coordinadora de la
licenciatura de negocios globales de la
universidad iberoamericana de ciudad de
méxico gracias a la doctora maribel por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francés 24 realmente un gusto las
implicaciones que tiene entonces el
ingreso de suecia y finlandia a notar
cuáles son
aguantaron muy buenos días gusto
saludarte respondiendo a tu atinada
pregunta me parece que debemos de
visualizar que se va a redibujar un
nuevo mapa geopolítico en europa a la
luz de esta posible ampliación en notar
esta alianza militar que ciclo durante
la guerra fría como un mecanismo de
defensa de los miembros pues se ha ido
agrandando se ha ido expandiéndose de
ahí que yo pongo sobre la mesa también a
la organización y ahora de cambiar
posiblemente de 30 a 32 miembros donde
posiblemente se resuelva en la próxima
cumbre de la otan a celebrarse en madrid
a finales del mes de junio pues entonces
ahora esto enciende las alarmas tanto en
el kremlin pero también en el cardado
interesante ver que ahora está este tema
sobre la mesa pero del gobierno del
hogar donde ya turquía ha dicho que los
conflictos del pasado no se olvidan y
estará muy atento a ver si si logran
negociar algo a cambio o definitivamente
si le da el veto a estas dos naciones
nórdicas que pues acusan de ser el
epicentro de agrupaciones terroristas de
grupos que están en contra del gobierno
turco raúl eso quería conversar con
usted a nivel hablemos entonces de
turquía porque turquía ahora si empieza
a aparecer en todo este escenario
político no
así es en este tablero ahora turquía es
quien está en el centro de la
conversación
donde puede ser que él logre negociar
algo a cambio con respecto a que tenga
acceso a armas que suecia y finlandia
garanticen al gobierno turco que no van
a seguir financiando este tipo de
agrupaciones que trae pues todo este
componente político ya que el pkk es un
partido de trabajadores donde pues ha
habido internamente una guerrilla en
turquía y esto ha generado ciertas
confrontaciones desde el pasado así que
ahora se están reviviendo esas heridas
que parece ser que no han cicatrizado a
un roe claro a nivel porque entonces
ahora la amenaza de rusia que parece
unos días contundentes pero otros días
el barça bis la suavizan digamos dicen
que pues si es amenazante después dicen
que no a menos que desplieguen todo el
armamento hoy precisamente la bruja dijo
que pues no porque también suecia y
finlandia en siempre ha realizado estos
ejercicios como socios de la otan y no
como miembros entonces que es realmente
piensa el kremlin y también le quiero
preguntar si la demil putin está listo
para abrir otro frente de guerra con
estos dos países porque ha dicho también
que podría empezar estas maniobras
técnicos militares como en su momento
del anuncio con ucrania
me parece que has puesto el dedo en la
llaga muy puntual raúl porque justamente
veo que este cambio de matiz en la
narrativa del kremlin con respecto al
ingreso de suecia y finlandia
respondería a que ahorita la capacidad
de rusia en términos de ofensiva militar
no le da para entonces cumplir sus
amenazas de abrir un nuevo frente al
norte apuntando hacia finlandia entonces
es una manera de decir pues ahorita no
es una prioridad que ingrese mientras no
hay un despliegue militar con mi
frontera porque ahorita todos los
esfuerzos están concentrados
lo que tiene que ver al sur de ucrania
no han logrado avanzar en lo que
requerían recordaremos que también en
esta guerra y vida se está dando en
paralelo la guerra de los energéticos
pero también la guerra de las cadenas de
suministro alimentarias entonces ya con
tantos frentes abiertos reunión
veo muy viable que responda esto que
entonces ahorita no estaría rusia con
toda la estructura y la arquitectura
militar lista para poder calentar
motores y abriendo nuevos boquetes
militares claro ariel pero también con
esta adhesión casi inminente de suecia y
finlandia a la organización atlántica
pues se vería un despliegue militar
hacia las fronteras con rusia oa lo
mejor sí lo están estos dos países se
abstienen de hacerlo pues cerca a la
frontera sede con rusia para evitar
también un conflicto como lo vio usted
totalmente y me parece que justo eso es
lo que responde a este cambio de
política exterior bajo el paraguas de la
neutralidad de estos dos países nórdicos
el hecho de que sientan que su seguridad
está siendo amenazada es lo que nos ha
motivado sin embargo me parece posible
ver que a lo mejor algunos ajustes algún
cambio de estrategia por parte de lo tal
a la luz de la cumbre a realizarse
dentro de más de un mes y pues
posiblemente suecia y finlandia entonces
estuvieran a lo mejor poniendo sobre la
mesa algunas directrices claras para que
no genere y no arda más la confrontación
con respecto a rusia se mueven mucho las
fichas en este tablero robert y hay
algunas algunos temas como este en
particular habrá que esperamos hasta
finales de junio para ver hacia dónde se
mueve esta nueva directriz de dothan y
por lo tanto hacia dónde se moverá el
péndulo
a vladimir putin claro a nivel y
precisamente hablando de blaine y el
putting también poniendo sobre la mesa
entremos un poco en aguas pantanosas
sobre el posible uso de armas nucleares
no se habla obviamente que de esta
adhesión de suecia y finlandia a la otan
pues ésta hallaría digamos otro
conflicto que tan cerca o qué tan lejos
estamos de un posible conflicto nuclear
y también es pues que le dice a las
personas que creen que eso ya es
inminente como lo lee usted
fíjate que la lectura que yo veo es que
actualmente estamos viviendo ya una
segunda guerra fría 2.0 es decir esta
confrontación
en diferentes aristas nos recuerda la
guerra fría en el pasado pero con nuevos
matices nuevos actores nuevas amenazas y
riesgos globales a acumulándose todas
las crisis del año 2021 y que en un
escenario de guerra pues entonces
estamos viviendo raúl esa es la aventura
que veo
demasiados frentes abiertos donde ante
la gran interdependencia de las
economías y una gran conectividad
mundial es impensable crear que
cualquier movimiento dirigido para
afectar únicamente la economía rusa pues
es obvio y evidente que esto se da en un
efecto búmeran donde cada vez nos
acercamos más a una recesión global por
lo tanto tanto occidente como rusia los
vemos ahora ya mucho más cautelosos en
cuanto este juego de sanciones aplicadas
de un lado hacia el otro porque también
desde crear bien están moviendo muy bien
sus fichas porque quieren dibujar una
nueva arquitectura financiera
internacional al exigir que el rubro se
utilice como posible la vida en moneda
de cambio pero también no olvidemos el
tema de las cadenas de suministro
alimenticias que cada se disponen a
temblar más la seguridad alimentaria